hi I'm Reese Witherspoon from little
fires everywhere hi I'm Megan Stott and
I'm Jade Pettijohn
hey I'm Gavin Lewis hi I'm Lexi
Underwood hi I'm Jordan alsace from
little fires everywhere and I'm Kerry
Washington also from little fires
everywhere and we are here to play
BuzzFeed's first times oh my goodness
I'm gonna start lying now just so you
know everything is a lie
when I first met you in person I was
like who is that girl she's so sweet
when I first met you in person I was
like oh my god I know who that girl is
but then I got to know Carrie and our
relationship has grown and become richer
and deeper through times up mm-hmm
really sharing ideas about what how we
want to see safety in the workplace and
also just being kind of in each other's
tribe and sharing what it's like to
start a production company what it's
like to be a working mom what it's like
to balance your marriage while you're
thinking after it's really cool for me
to see you step into a leadership
position that you so deserve and that
you really feel excited about it well I
love that thank you
she's an amazing partner I told you that
I was lying about yeah oh oh it's a good
actor yeah on my callback that's when I
met Jade and yeah he read together and
when I first met you I was like wow
she's really professional and then I got
on set with her I'm like wow wow she's
really funny and never mind she's not
just professional yeah I mean I thought
you were just really bright like the
second I met you in the audition you
were just I mean your character is very
moody and Gary likes Donny Martens I
wore the same outfit for every single
audition I worked Doc Martens yeah they
were red and then a red t-shirt and
every single time then I would come and
I'd be like I'm tough no you were
talking I was light and professional
yeah and I looked you up and I was like
oh my gosh she's so many followers
really like went through your Instagram
I was like oh that's cute and I was
right so hard not to like them but I
probably like like four of them I was
like this cute and I went through really
good kind of it back
[Music]
I'm lucky yeah I did the same on you
though yeah you got a minute we all
instance happens because you're like
what do I have in common with this
person once can I talk to them about you
got a no yeah that's how it works I
hated everybody I am still dude yeah
there was chemistry already there
between all of us I think you know
everybody's just so talented
like our first table read I was like
immediately blown away but also like
when we were all auditioning together
mm-hm like I just remember like the
first time that I met Gavin and did the
Moody and pearl scene with you I was
just like these can ism means I'm an
only child so these people are like my
sibling self I don't want it just me we
return a compliment
and everyone was incredibly talented I
think we lucked out I will say that Rhys
and I met at a kind of work shopping
meeting reading of a scribe yeah at
Leonardo DiCaprio's house that's right a
little name drop and it was for a movie
that eventually went but neither of us
was in it no neither was we oh that's
true you know what one thing that is
public and it came out last year I
auditioned so hard for clueless and I
didn't get it really is so hard for it
and I I did - did you I did that would
have been a different we should do like
we could do like doing a remake recreate
yeah and then yes with us that would be
so fun
I know I was in an airport once and I
yet met this comedian Yakov Smirnoff and
I was like oh my god this guy is so bad
as I can't believe something plain as me
when I was a kid I was at like toddler
age I want to say maybe around 3 my
parents brought me my very cool parents
brought me to a peaches and herb
concert whoa and as they were walking
down the aisle
singing they like touched my hand
because it was a baby in the audience
that was my first brush with greatness
oh I love it
everyone on set that was the first time
I really met anybody who is famous like
grease and Jerry and all of them I was
like yes I'd never met anybody meeting
race was so cool
I think oh cool I think the first
celebrity I ever met was actually the
voice of Bart Simpson Nancy Cartwright
she introduced herself in the Bart
Simpson voice and I was like what this
is incredible and it made my like six
year old dreams come true I think the
first level he ever met would have been
all three of the Jonas Brothers it would
have started with Nick because I want to
contest because that was diabetic and I
had a nonprofit organization that I was
I was trying to save the oceans when I
was little and that's actually something
I want to get back to and he sort of
inspired me because I was diabetic that
was when I was newly diagnosed and he
sort of inspired me for living well with
diabetes and I think he was actually
part of the inspiration start acting so
yeah that was pretty it was a pretty
impressionable first celebrity meeting I
worked on a feature film that was like
direct-to-dvd when I was like 14 and Tom
Arnold like played the villain in it and
I met him and I was just like well
that's Tom Arnold and I remember he was
only there for one day and he just came
in and he was like super professional
super nice and then he was gone never
saw this guy ever again
he was like in and out hi I'm Conor nice
to meet you just dips probably Megan
good I remember it was like my first
time in LA and I was about like nine
years old and my mom and I we were at
Roscoe's at the time what was it jumping
the broom was like my favorite movie to
watch on TV so I was so excited to meet
her and actually flash forward to summer
of 2018 I actually just played her
daughter and an indie film so it was
crazy how it like all came full circle
but I was so excited to meet her
you know I just remember it was such a
big deal to be talking so openly about
the inner lives of women and their
friendships but also about domestic
violence and portraying that in the real
raw emotional way that it was Nicole
Kidman's performance is incredible the
end and so there was a lot of emotional
response to that but also enjoying Laura
Dern's comedic talent yes all of you the
the magic of that ensemble it was a
really fun group of women I don't think
we ever expected it to be
as culturally a touchstone as people
enjoyed it so thank you for watching I
think that would be my same reaction to
it's just a big thank you like everybody
kept telling us before scandal aired
what a risk it was for a black woman to
be the lead of a network drama that it
hadn't happened in 40 years so there was
kind of a sense or a questioning like
will people tune in will people watch so
when people did show up we were just so
grateful we were so happy that people
were willing to show up for our heroes
to look like more than just one thing
something along the lines of there was
so much juice and mystery
yeah when like I first read the book I
was like wow this is very interesting
look cool they're gonna do it the script
and then I read the script I was like
wow pun intended it was very fiery the
book was really emotional for me it
really explored motherhood in a way that
I hadn't had some of those descriptions
in it and also this idea that sometimes
other women mother you I've had many
different women in my life who have
become mothers to me and helped me
through times that my own mother didn't
have experience with or wasn't there
standing next to me I really identified
with that part of it it was just a very
profound experience because they do
think that we tend to think of mothers
in very binary terms there's good
mothers and bad mothers you know and and
not to really dive into the beautiful
complexity of what it means to be a
mother than unique
and rewards we had a beautiful room of
writers who worked so fantastically
together but we were really weighing in
on scripts and helping those scripts
evolve and giving the writers room to be
as brilliant as they were and we got to
be sort of 90s consultants because you
have our teenagers in the 90s yeah we
were like that's not a thing but a fast
way and we both were rollerblades for
sure I read it I read it during the
audition process and I really really
liked the book yeah I was just super
excited to bring the character to life
that no one had ever brought to life
before my first time reading the book
was actually also during the audition
process couldn't put it down and that
was the same thing with the scripts you
know as soon as we got I got like all
eight scripts at once and I just like
binge read all the scripts I read the
book after because I sort of wanted to
because I knew there were some
discrepancies and then I read the book
after and I was just like wow they're
both amazing oh I know I was on Jeopardy
was I in jeopardy don't worry a question
on Jeopardy I would know I was on a
wheel of fortune you were they said my
whole even the Witherspoon the part long
part I thought the answer was the answer
is really I was like okay this is it I
have arrived yeah Wow also you know like
the very first time I was in TV Guide
yeah oh yeah number how important it was
been huge my grandma called me is that
urine Davey had the first time I
realized I was famous I was walking on
the street in New York in Chelsea I was
on 23rd Street and somebody said Carrie
and I was like hi and I gave them a hug
and then I stepped back and I was like
trying to place them and they were like
I loved you and say blessed dance and I
was like oh my god I just gave up to a
complete stranger I don't know this
person at all like I should probably
have different boundaries now but you
didn't know now you still hug hug
strangers Legally Blonde the first one I
saw was a man on the moon oh yeah oh
yeah yeah that was their first no yeah
that movie that movie was
my eyes out and then I watch like bleep
on and I was like oh I like her yeah did
you ever quote well I tried to make it
really nonchalant I don't remember what
it was but I said like what like it's
hard but I'm pretty sure she seemed it
was like you're doing legally one right
now I think it would have been legally
blonde it was a good first impression of
race I was obsessed with Legally Blonde
I just loved Reese Witherspoon she's an
incredible person and she's even more
incredible as outlets probably walk the
line because I'm a big walking fan like
she did so good it was dope oh this is a
good question because I do think women
need to talk about money more often and
our successes not just our devastations
well first of all the first time I was
able to afford a rental house that had
air conditioning was such a huge idea
because la was really hot and I couldn't
and I lived in a lot of little places I
had no air conditioning I was just
sweating y'all huge deal and then the
first time I ever bought a house and
that was a huge moment in my life and I
feel really proud of that accomplishment
when I did save the last dance they were
still giving pretty omim cash mm-hmm I
was living in Chicago was my first
studio film and they handed me an
envelope full of cash where I come from
somebody gives you an envelope full of
cash you're doing something illegal so I
was like what is this and they explained
it to me and I proceeded to hide that
Weekly cash under my mattress and at the
end of save the last dance I bought my
first laptop because I had saved my per
diem throughout the film that's so cool
and I was like I have to remember to do
this I have to remember to keep paying
myself first right
[Music]
lots of Tears
I got the call and I think I think you
said that this happened to you too or my
team was like so we have some news for
you you know we're really sorry Megan
but you book the little fires yeah
literally I started crying when they
were like yeah bad news for you and I
started crying I was like okay I didn't
get this those like my dream job and
then they told make on it and I started
screaming it was the best moment of all
time I loved it
me too me too I was screaming and crying
I was jumping up and down I'm sure my
neighbors were probably like super
annoyed with me but it's fine it was a
fantastic moment I know no word here I
have I had a friend over when I first
found out and I was crazy excited and
she's sort of celebrated with me and it
was good it was a really good moment I
was very very excited I cried I burst
into tears ran upstairs to my pops and I
just like was like I got it like oh my
god I just like started crying and I was
so so excited like I can't even describe
the feeling this is incredible
the first premiere of a movie I was in
was called the man in the moon and I was
14 years old and I went down to La Brea
to a vintage store and I bought myself a
little vintage dress and then I wore my
cowboy boots with it because I thought
it was cute I thought it was really cool
that our own sports [ __ ] came to the
premiere I have no idea still to this
day why I was used to go to can often
cuz I worked with a company that has a
big presence there and I had previously
been at a photo shoot for People
magazine where I had worn a dress by a
little-known designer named Jason Wu and
I loved the dress and I asked him if he
could make it for me in green and so I
was the first person to wear Jason Wu
internationally on an international
carpet and I wore this gorgeous green
gown that he made for me and can and
I'll never forget it cuz was the
beginning of our friendship and of
course his meteoric rise to fame you
were clothed so beautifully I'm watching
you on the red carpet isn't she the best
carpet I love a dress I love a moment in
red carpet mo you really go there with
style and it's really fun to watch I try
to think of it as like performance art
yeah I think it's it's these moments to
create magic with a team of other
artisans coming together yeah it's
really cool otherwise I wouldn't get
through it I have to make it something
like creative and silly otherwise I'd be
like no
[Laughter]
[Music]